all the society is doing is leeching off
the ghetto they use the ghetto for their
pain for their sorrow for their culture
for their music for their happiness for
their movies to talk about boys in the
hood you know I'm saying I don't want to
be another young I don't want to be 50
years old at a B et we shall overcome
achieve with awards you know I'm saying
uh-uh not me
you know I'm gonna when they see me they
know that every day when I'm breathing
it's for us to go farther you know every
time I speak I want the truth to come
out you know say every time I speak I
want to shiver you know I don't want
them to be like they know what I'm gonna
say because it's polite they know what
I'm gonna say and even if I get in
trouble you know I'm saying that ain't
that what we're supposed to do it's I'm
not saying I'm gonna rule the world or
I'm gonna change the world but I
guarantee that I will spark the brain
that will change the world and that's
our job is to spark somebody else
watching us we might not be the ones but
let's not be selfish and because we're
not gonna change the world let's not
talk about how we should change it I
don't know how to change it but I know
if I keep talking about how dirty it is
out here some are gonna clean it up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you just watch - amazing clips of tupac
shakur take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]